always mung won joe strikes a deal my
life has been turned upside down what
she's agreed to and what it means for
michael kovrig and michael fever it's
completely up to the top political
powers in beijing also breaking the
catholic bishops of canada apologize the
mia culpa for their role in residential
schools potential help for certain
coveted patients we can't just sit idle
by and let them get infected and
deteriorate the roadblocks to getting
this antibody cocktail in canada
and where in the world is wally he
doesn't need a passport to travel the
whimsical walrus making a splash
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with major breaking news in
the case of mong wan zhou after nearly
three years under house arrest in
vancouver the huawei executive is free
and on route back to china at this hour
because she struck a deal with u.s
prosecutors new video shows the air
china flight men was on taking off from
vancouver international airport shortly
after she left the courthouse with the
u.s deal now in place the request to
extradite her from canada to the states
has been dropped and for the first time
since her arrest she spoke publicly
over the past three years
my life has been turned upside down
it was disruptive time for me
as a mother
a wife
and a company executive
but i believe
every cloud
has a silver lining i will never forget
all the good wishes
i've received
from people around the world robin gill
has tonight's top story on the deal that
monk struck
[Music]
mong wan zhou is free and thanking
canada i'd like to thank the honorable
associate chief justice home
for her fairness in the holy ghost
proceedings and the canadian government
for upholding the rule of law this was
the first time since her extradition
battle began we've heard her speak to my
family
to my friends
to everyone
who provided
care and help for me
three years of legal battles over after
12 minutes in bc's supreme court earlier
the cfo and heiress to the huawei empire
appeared via video conference in a new
york courtroom she and the american
government signed a deferred prosecution
agreement
we don't know the full terms of the dpa
she may face significant fines but mung
doesn't have to plead guilty u.s
prosecutors said that if mung complies
the criminal charges against her will be
dismissed bank fraud wire fraud and two
related conspiracy counts and it will
end december 1st 2022
four years from her arrest at
vancouver's airport richard kerland an
immigration lawyer has been watching her
case from day one you don't want to link
the expense of litigation and you don't
want someone to go scot-free
so
the mid-ground is the fur prosecution
agreement where
you say you're not guilty but you're
admitting to wrongdoing and paying a
hefty fine okay let's move her back in
mung was arrested in 2018 at the request
of the united states always maintaining
her innocence now she's willing to take
some responsibility admitting in a
statement of facts she concealed the
truth of huawei's business in iran and
that she made multiple
misrepresentations and engaged in a
concerted effort to deceive a global
financial institution she was accused of
using a huawei subsidiary skycom to sell
computer equipment to iran and
misleading hsbc's american banks to do
that deal which is a violation of
sanctions against iran now that hsbc has
pulled the plug on its u.s banking
operations there's no reason to continue
prosecution against huawei and maine
hmong did shed some tears when she
realized she was free but she didn't
bother to go home to her multi-million
dollar house in vancouver which has been
part of her house arrest instead she
made a beeline for the airport boarded a
flight to china free of that ankle
bracelet free of those security guards
that she had to pay for she realized she
finally had her freedom and this now
puts an end to that sega at least one
chapter of it that put canada in the
middle of a war between two superpowers
pharah
robin gill at vancouver international
airport thank you robin the deal with
mong won joe comes at a tense time in
u.s china relations with president biden
ramping up international pressure on
china over its conduct in recent days
jackson proskow joins us now from
washington jackson what more do we know
about how today's agreement with hmong
came to be
well far on negotiations with mong wong
zhou and the u.s justice department
reportedly began last summer under
president trump but the two sides
finally came to this agreement against a
backdrop of mounting pressure on china
over the treatment of those two detained
canadians something the u.s secretary of
state raised during a tense meeting with
his chinese counterpart back in march we
know that prime minister trudeau and
president biden have spoken repeatedly
about working to secure the release of
the two michaels biden himself publicly
raised the issue human beings are not
bartering ships
you know we're going to work together
until we get their safe return
so far even though the justice
department is politically independent
today's decision at least has the
benefit of removing canada as the middle
man in his tense situation between the
u.s and china and perhaps helps to thaw
relations with all three countries if it
does eventually result in the freedom
for the two detained canadians yes so
jackson what does this mean then for the
relationship between the u.s and china
moving forward will it help it improve
well you know big picture biden has
spoken extensively about his desire for
competition not conflict with china in
fact while mong wang zhou was in court
today biden was actually at the white
house meeting with the leaders of india
australia and japan to talk about the
very issue of countering china and of
course just last week the u.s agreed to
that pact with australia and great
britain for nuclear-powered submarines
again to counter china's growing
influence of course even with mong's
release the core issue at the center of
all of this the reach and influence of
chinese technology giant huawei is
unlikely to disappear and china has
already now sent this very clear message
that countries who support u.s efforts
could end up paying a very steep price
farah
jackson prescott washington thank you
jackson
a prominent arm of the catholic church
is apologizing to indigenous peoples of
canada for the suffering experienced in
residential schools in a statement the
canadian conference of catholic bishops
expresses their profound remorse and
apologize unequivocally they say many
catholics participated in the
residential school system leading to the
suppression of indigenous languages
culture and spirituality and they
acknowledge the grave abuses committed
by some members of the catholic
community they say they are fully
committed to the process of healing and
reconciliation hundreds of unmarked
graves were found at the sites of
several former residential schools
earlier this year
the head of emergency medicine for the
alberta medical association is warning
the province is close to implementing
its critical triage protocol
we haven't triggered it yet but we're
literally sitting and standing on the
edge of the cliff right now
dr paul park says the critical triage
document is triggered when there are
only a couple of icu beds left across
the province but he notes surgeries are
already being canceled and transfers are
being delayed these are all components
of triage protocol new brunswick has
reimposed a state of emergency after
another record-breaking day of new
covenant 19 cases the order means a
return to household bubbles and limits
on close contacts and gatherings premier
blaine higgs says the order will be
reviewed every two weeks
canada's top doctor says active talks
are now underway with other countries to
allow the entry of canadians with mixed
covid19 vaccine doses dr teresa tam says
the public health agency of canada is
presenting data to countries like the
u.s on the effectiveness of a mixed dose
schedule
the issue isn't with the mra vaccines in
terms of interchangeability is
for example they have not used
astrazeneca vaccine in the united states
and certainly not a mixed dose schedule
and as a result they don't have
domestically generated information on
that front
tam says the u.s is still in the process
of deliberation on accepting mixed doses
canadians are asked to check on specific
country requirements before making
travel plans
the world health organization is now
backing an expensive antibody treatment
for high risk covid19 patients experts
say it could help some people avoid
serious outcomes but in canada the
supply is limited and provinces are slow
to offer the treatment if at all
jamie morocco reports
as long covet patient lisa urbanski
struggles to do what used to be so
simple
she can't help but wonder if early
intervention could have helped it's
incredibly hard to get up in the morning
incredibly hard it's almost like there's
a heaviness
in my brain monoclonal antibodies
offered commonly in the u.s might have
prevented the 37-year-old's pain we
caught it early early enough on that
this would really make a huge impact for
the better the world health organization
now agrees it says a monoclonal antibody
cocktail may keep people with mild to
moderate covenanting out of the icu
if we haven't been immunized or we
haven't been previously infected we
don't have those antibodies so one way
to
help us along in fighting infection in
the absence of being having immunity is
to actually administer
those kind of antibodies canada has just
six thousand doses of the regeneron drug
with three thousand more on the way
compared to the three million the biden
administration has procured its peanuts
the area where there's the biggest gap
in terms of
having
an effective treatment is for
outpatients with mild disease while
regeneron may fill this gap provinces
aren't using what limited supply they
have at twenty five hundred dollars a
pop canadian experts say the hefty price
tag is partially to blame it's not
really fundamentally about cost um
there's access but also
feasibility of delivery until recently
the treatment was only administered
intravenously a roadblock dr don vinn is
navigating around creating a safe space
to offer the drug in montreal for
immunocompromised coveted patients we
can't just
sit idle by and let them
let them get infected and deteriorate
vin hopes a new injectable version of
the drug will make it easier for all
hospitals and clinics to offer i would
have given
everything i have to have something to
help me a tool we have been slow to use
that could help vulnerable covid
patients early on jamie rocker global
news toronto multiplying calls to better
protect women in london
coming up the murder case prompting
demands for the government to take
action
investigators in london are asking for
the public's help as they try to solve
the murder of 28 year old sabine anissa
it's believed the teacher was on a
five-minute walk to meet a friend when
she was killed a 38-year-old man has
been arrested but police are also
looking for this man detectives released
this video showing him walking in the
area where nessa was attacked as crystal
commansing reports there's grief and
anger not just over nessa's death but a
growing epidemic of violence against
women
i just want to say
thank you for everyone
heartbroken sabine nessa's sister tried
to tell the crowd about the loving young
teacher taken from her family
mixed in with the tears and candles
there is anger here so we need every
member of our community to come together
and say no more
last friday the 28 year old was on her
way to meet a friend she took the path
through a connecting park it was there
her body was discovered the next day for
too long the burden of women's safety
has been on women's shoulders and we're
just tired
tired of being afraid tired of mourning
this mound of flowers grew a few months
back in memory of sarah everard she was
walking home from a friend's house in
march when she was kidnapped raped and
strangled to death wayne cousin a
metropolitan police constable pleaded
guilty to her murder
in the uk it is estimated a woman is
killed by a man every three days a
statistic the mayor of london says is
unacceptable i think this uh
you know deserves the same priority as
counter-terrorism
i agree with the
inspector who called this an epidemic if
the government just listened and did
rather than thought and talked i think
we'd see a lot more progress one of the
most moving moments of the vigil was
when everyone in the crowd was asked to
repeat her name three separate times
sabine and while there are calls for the
violence against women to end the
reality of the situation literally just
steps away police officers in hazmat
suits searching for clues
crystal gamson global news
london
ahead from halifax to berlin thousands
around the world march to fight climate
change
thousands of youth activists flooded
streets across canada it's the first
mass climate strike since the pandemic
ground large gatherings to a halt the
international fridays for future
movement is calling on governments to do
more including adding programs to school
curriculums and ending eviction from
homeless camps in ontario they're asking
the newly re-elected liberal government
to deliver on the climate promises that
were made during the campaign
more than 1400 climate events were held
globally from the uk to japan india and
sierra leone demonstrators were warning
the planet faces imminent danger if
there isn't a sharp cut in greenhouse
gas emissions in germany tens of
thousands of people rallied outside
parliament led by teenage activist greta
tunberg who sparked the mass climate
initiative three years ago she's
accusing politicians of falling short
saying their programs aren't
far-reaching enough to limit global
warming
swimming into the spotlight next
tracking the journey of wally the walrus
tonight we're ending the newscast with a
story about a traveling walrus named
wally
the arctic mammal gained fame while
summering in europe and was seen in
ireland earlier this month eric sorensen
tonight on where in the world is wally
like an explorer in the new world he
first set flipper on the shores of
southern ireland last spring
next stop the coast of wales they called
him wally naturally a four-year-old
one-ton arctic walrus probably a male
this poor guy is turned up over here on
a very very long journey very very far
away from home
one worry is that walruses are losing
sea ice to climate change and venturing
further from the arctic they're losing
habitat so we can expect to see more and
more of those arctic species
becoming vagrants and becoming displaced
from their native habitats
but out on his own it's likely this
intrepid pinniped is touring an
adventurer like so many teenagers says
one canadian walrus expert teenage males
that seem to have this wanderlust it
seems that all animals have
this natural curiosity about the world
well this guy sure does he looks nothing
like any other walrus you've ever
actually he looks like every other
walrus but wally has identifiable scars
on his flippers in 10b whales he lounged
for days the locals watched and shops
sold wally pillows and play things
he came from somewhere in the arctic
part explorer part tourist swam
thousands of kilometers to ireland and
the uk was later spotted as far south as
france and the waters off northern spain
and then back to ireland this time
county cork and finally a three week 900
kilometer swim to iceland
whenever he surfaced he just wanted a
little sun a little rest on a dinghy
here or something more sturdy there and
maybe take a boat for a spin like any
sights here bristly-faced blubbery and
seemingly benevolent they're sort of
whimsical they've got personality
character
they're just such an amazing wonderful
animal a massive mammal has made waves
across the north atlantic
is now feeding and around iceland
packing it on to get him to that next
step of his journey reaching iceland
probably means he's on his way back to
the high arctic to be with other
walruses
what a story he'll have
eric sorensen global news toronto
a walrus with wanderlust after the past
18 months i'm sure many of us can relate
that's global national for this friday
night i'm farah nasser thank you so much
for spending part of your evening with
us
tonight's your canada is beautiful
northern bay newfoundland and labrador
robin gill will be with you on the
anchor desk tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and each other
[Music]
[Applause]
you